salut à tous aujourd'hui nous sommes
samedi c'est le jour du master class je
vous l'avais annoncé la semaine dernière
aujourd'hui on voit comment réussir ses
examens en tout cas c'est une première
partie j'en ferai sûrement d'autres sur
ce sujet là et aujourd'hui on va se
concentrer exclusivement sur la révision
la manière d'apprendre et la manière de
réviser
on va apprendre à apprendre on va parler
d'une méthode très intéressant pour ça
les cartes heuristiques les cartes
heuristiques que vous connaissez
peut-être aujourd'hui sous le nom de
mind mapping concept au départ qui a été
pensée par aristote et en 1960 tony
buzan dont on a déjà parlé dans ces
vidéos a développé tout un concept
autour de ça l'idée même des my maps est
très simple c'est d'exploiter les
chemins mnésiques entre deux neurones
quand deux neurones se connecte à l'aide
d'une idée ils font une espèce de santé
on appelle ça une trace mnésique pour
vous donner une image c'est comme si
vous alliez dans une forêt où il n'ya
pas de chemin et vous marchez tout droit
ça va commencer à créer un petit chemin
parce que vous allez pousser des
branches vous allez peut-être cassé un
petit peu de feuillages vous allez créer
un petit sentier ça va être un peu dur
la première fois mais plus vous allez
prendre ce chemin plus le sentier sera
dégagée et accessible mais au bout de x
au passage ce sera devenu complètement
dégagée et vous pourrez marcher
tranquillement par ce chemin là dans la
forêt c'est exactement ce qui se passe
avec la trace mnésique la première fois
le lien à faire entre les deux neurones
va être compliqué au tout départ mais
plus vous allez utiliser ce chemin là en
fait plus vous à les réviser
plus vous allez faire appel à ce lien la
pluie va se renforcer et à la fin il
sera quasiment automatique
mais le mad men c'est encore plus malin
que ça ça utilise également le geste
halte c'est la tendance car notre
cerveau a complété les choses si je vous
dise elle vous pensez quasiment
instantanément à poivre parce que le
chemin qui a été lié efforts entre les
deux est le cerveau envie d'anticiper et
de compléter votre chemin neuronale fait
en sorte de compléter à l'avance
d'anticiper les informations dont vous
avez besoin et donc vous laisse r comme
ça sur un plateau c'est principalement
grâce à ces deux choses là que le my
maps est un outil très puissant pour les
révisions et donc pour réussir ses
examens
si vous n'avez jamais vu que vous
connaissiez pas le nom je vous en faire
voir quelques-uns c'est une espèce
d'outils holistique et graphique
voilà comme ceci vous en fais passer
quelques-uns qui peut s'appliquer à tous
qui est cognitif donc la mémoire la
créativité toutes les formes de pensée
quelle qu'elle soit créé un my maps et
cartographié l'information au lieu de
faire de la prise de notes propre
organisée comme on fait habituellement
on va la rendre plus graphique on va la
rendre plus nourrissante pour le cerveau
vous savez je vous le dis souvent le
cerveau m
maj quand vous allez créer vos premiers
my maps vous allez place et
l'information principale au centre si
possible par une image ça marche
beaucoup mieux ça peut être quelque
chose que vous prenez de l'ordinateur ça
peut être quelque chose que vous
dessinez même si vous dessinez très mal
même moi je suis capable de faire un my
maps alors qu'on a vu la qualité de mes
dessins l'autre jour et ensuite vous
allez place et les ramifications si je
devais cartographier avec un my maps le
mental blog la chaîne youtube
je mettrai mentale blog en plein milieu
je mettrai peut être un cerveau en
dessin et je ferai une ramification qui
partiraient vers l'explication une autre
vers master class j'ouvrirai
l'information par exemple master class
sur une branche qui part sur la mémoire
une branche qui partent sur les
mathématiques vous allez créer un peu
comme un arbre des ramifications
appliquée à des révisions à appliquer à
de la connaissance à des choses qu'on
doit prendre pour base un examen il est
très simple de faire les my mac globaux
sur toute l'information ou de faire des
petits mymaps spécifiques à chaque chose
qu'on doit prendre soi même ça peut
marcher pour tous même juste pour une
fiche littéraire pour un bac de français
aussi bien que pour des études de
médecins l'essentiel c'est de combiner
les mots les couleurs et les images
le but final c'est que votre cerveau
prennent une photo de sa donc vous allez
le nourrir de toute cette logique
d'image de tout ce que vous y avez amis
de la forme des branches de la manière
dont vous allez écrire les mots du
relief que vous allez mettre dedans des
images des couleurs quand vous allez
repenser à votre information principale
au thème est ce que vous avez mis au
centre
l'ensemble va commencer à se dessiner
dans votre tête et chaque élément chaque
gros thème chaque logique qui va vous
revenir va faire rappelle après à toute
l'information que vous avez déjà
engendré au départ en l'apprenant et
grâce au geste at le fait de penser à
une partie de la carte de la manne maps
va faire que votre cerveau va penser à
tout le reste il va compléter cette
image là c'est selon moi et je suis pas
seul à penser ça la meilleure méthode
pour apprendre pour réviser pour
engranger de la connaissance dans le
temps en la répertoriant d'une manière
maligne dans son cerveau une fois que
vous avez créé un my maps
il faut forcément le réviser il faut le
retenir c'est extrêmement simple une
fois que vous l'avez créer 20 minutes
après vous le reprenez vous le réviser
un petit peu vous leur détailler vous le
regardez de nouveau vous faites ça
également le lendemain une fois que vous
l'avez fait le lendemain vous leur posez
vous le reprenez sept jours plus tard
une fois vous avez fait ça vous le
reprenez un mois plus tard une fois que
vous avez fait ça vous le reprenez trois
mois plus tard une fois que vous avez
fait ça à vous le reprenez six mois plus
tard à partir de ce moment là on pourra
considérer qu'il est rentré dans la
mémoire à long terme et que vous ne
l'oublierez plus après suppose deux
choses la première c'est que vous avez
lu et compris ou écouter les
informations principales que vous avez
traduit ensuite par prise de notes en
main
et ce après suppose encore une fois que
vous avez mis beaucoup de couleurs
beaucoup de richesses beaucoup de
logique de votre logique à vous à
l'intérieur de cette carte là quand je
parle de relief c'est aussi bien pour
les mots par exemple si j'écris grand je
vais l'écrire vraiment grand si j'écris
petit je vais l'écrire vraiment petit ça
marche aussi pour le relief que vous
allez donner aux branches les branches
principales moi j'ai tendance à les
faire beaucoup plus grosse c'est très
facile à faire c'est pas long ça prend
pas beaucoup de temps vous avez vu les
révisions c'est pareil 20 minutes après
1 jour 7 jours un mois trois mois six
mois
si vous voulez aller plus loin là dedans
ce que je vous recommande vous pouvez
vous procurer un des livres de tony
buzan il en a écrit un avec son frère
barry s'appelle dessine moi
l'intelligence
il est très très complet avec les
exemples de magma à l'intérieur je vous
en faire voir un d'ailleurs ça c'est un
magma pour parvenir à une vie équilibrée
sas en est un sur la créativité sa
centenaire d'un cours d'histoire c'est
très intéressant c'est le début de la
seconde guerre mondiale je vous
conseille ce livre mais il existe
beaucoup d'autres livres d'autres
auteurs d'ailleurs peu importe lequel
vous choisirez c'est pas un placement de
produit ma seule envie c'est que vous en
choisissez un pour aller un petit peu
plus loin dans l'aventuré du my maps je
pense pas qu'on puisse tout dire en une
vidéo quand bien même c'est un master
class
il faudrait presque faire une formation
de deux trois heures rien que sur ce
sujet là comme souvent d'ailleurs pas le
master class n'hésitez pas non plus à le
faire découvrir à d'autres personnes je
pense que c'est applicable à tous les
domaines que ce soit pour faire un
discours pour organiser sa vie pour
organiser son travail pour apprendre des
choses peu importe c'est un outil très
très précieux et 6 masterclass vous
appuyez aussi un my maps facile pour me
faire savoir c'est de laisser un petit
pouce en l'air je vous mets tous les
biens dans les commentaires n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner avant de partir vous
pouvez laisser un petit commentaire
passer un bon week-end bon courage à
ceux qui ont des choses à apprendre à
réviser rendez vous demain à 11 heures
pour le prochain mentale blog ciao